August hasn't been in class since last  October we need him in the class it's a  budget thing are you gonna make sure my  son doesn't get shot walking over school  is that your son in there make it music  [Music]  music that makes a beat a minute he's  fragile  what's a night night you just go here to  with your creepy window game where y'all  talking I'm getting back in the game  this kid is a way back in August needs  therapy  but still he hasn't been right since his  sister got shot what are you doing I  here I'm just here for moral support  he can do big things in this world  but he has to be in this world  I will make you the most famous  seventeen-year-old in Roseland  I really do those type of things my son  was very happy before you started coming  around here keep listening to your music  want to be free  Chicago Brothers is dead and I'm  standing here  let's make some news  [Music]  you